[Music]
from the corner diner to more elegant
fare restaurants run by people of greek
heritage have had extraordinary success
in this country
and there may be no better example than
the levano's family and their three
generations
they've mastered the art of opening and
running restaurants in the new york city
area for over
50 years we sat down with them at modern
barn their restaurant in armonk new york
we all know how to cook we all have
culinary backgrounds
all we do is eat think drink food
we're cooking away at home altogether
for the levano's clan
nothing means more than the greek
traditions brought to this country by
their patriarch john
and chrissa the family matriarch you
went from washing dishes
to your own restaurant in
what three years i opened 14 restaurants
up to now
in my whole life it's a lot yes i was
putting
14 15 hours a day seven days a week my
first vacation was seven years later he
worked his vacation
so he would have that extra money i was
very passionate
and i think i did a good job
i think you did their legacy started
with a luncheonette
it's since expanded to more elegant fare
focusing on mediterranean seafood
what is it about the food business you
love i enjoyed
making new dishes i always talk with
myself
i emphasize a lot and i seafood fresh
fish
fresh always speaking of food here
let's just kind of go through the realm
of what we have
you see what we would be eating day
after christmas
our spanakopita the most classic of all
greek dishes is pastichio
which is a baked macaroni ground meat
bechamel dish
my mom's famous peas and artichokes with
fresh steal and onions
always beets with parsley a little extra
virgin olive oil
a nice bitter radicchio salad and rack a
lamb
with a dijon mustard bread crumb crust
the second generation put its own spin
on the new york dining scene
with molivos and oceana in midtown
so the kids kicked it up a notch yes
they did
nick the eldest sibling graduated from
the culinary institute of america
and soon opened the lavanos restaurant
with his brother bill
his younger sister karina wasn't far
behind
i just graduated and i was fortunate i
had a few months off
and i'll never forget in the fall of
1992 nick said
i just need someone to help me in front
of the house just help me just give me
until the holidays and that's it
and i never left
you reeled me right in tell me about
walking into the newest restaurant that
your two grandchildren
opened up i spoke to them from the
beginning
i'm giving you authority you're going to
run this place
johnny and nick lovanos launched usia in
hell's kitchen
four years ago i think when we first
opened up we had a vision that would be
more of a traditional greek restaurant
really yeah it kind of evolved into what
i like to say is a greek focused
american cuisine
things that aren't flavored and very
important to us as well to be
ambassadors of the greek cuisine so
it's uh i think just as the fact that
we're the third generation in the
business we're kind of giving
greek food another new generation of
cuisine and entering a whole new market
in the spirit of the old country i was
on a wine trip in greece
and i went hiking i put some herbs in my
glass and i had one of those light bulb
eureka moments
where i had a sip and i'm like wait a
second no one in greece is making
gin why not they have all this raw
material that's there
someone has to do it so i started
researching doing some recipe testing
and we created stray dog wild gin which
is basically a combination of all
different greek botanicals
mastica from verino cucumber and
mint and lemon juice refreshing
when you sit down and think about how
well off you are it all goes back to
your grandparents
what sacrifices did they make to ensure
you're standing here today
we realized what he was doing was a
sacrifice for us and i feel like some
people grow up resenting parents who
work too much
we saw the value of what he was doing
covet 19
is also keeping the levano's family and
their restaurants on high alert
at their westchester locations they
resorted to making deliveries
themselves so what keeps you guys going
we're very committed
it's tough it's never been a tougher
time but we've been through hard times
before and we're going to get through
this
getting through this means treasuring
the time they've spent together
the family dinners we now have together
every night we've all put on kovaten
but that's been fun that's been very
special actually we all live
very close all over so it's like my
big fat greek wedding yeah that's true
almost yeah the only thing we don't do
we don't do the lamb in the front we do
it in the back
cheers and they sent pictures to prove
it
unfortunately we didn't put it in the
piece but i did bring you gin
oh thank you yeah but apple really uh
yeah
brian took it all brian and tony and
tony bear
yeah yeah i'm sorry you know
this is the one you were texting us your
head brunch there right or lunch it was
we got to do a story right
right right right they're right down the
street yeah good stuff all right